sauf sur la proximité aux préoccupations
des Français il est majoritaire et très
majoritaire dans son soldat le socle
tient maintenant est-ce que Emmanuel
Macron peut rebondir je vais pas faire
de prédiction j'ai envie de dire lors du
premier mandat il a déjà rebondi trois
fois ce qui n'était jamais arrivé pour
un président hors période de
cohabitation de connaître trois rebonds
significatifs automne 2017 avec le le
vote des lois sur le code du travail il
arrive une partie de la droite il
redevient majoritaire post gilet jaune
le grand débat le parti de l'ordre le
rempart Emmanuel Macron face à la
chanlie il gagne une quinzaine de points
et il assure à son parti un score très
honorable aux élections européennes et
troisième rebond vous en parliez le
covid où il se passe un truc un truc
pardon quelque chose de jamais vu sous
la Cinquième République pendant deux ans
sa cote de popularité ne bouge pas elle
reste à 40% dans le baromètre JDD 45
dans le baromètre de bonnes opinions du
baromètre match parce que il y a une
sorte de glacis de popularité c'est le
président des crises le capitaine dans
la tempête et fait drapeau d'un côté par
rapport à la guerre en Ukraine le
président protecteur il est sorti de
cela complètement il paye le prix
classique d'un président en situation de
crise d'une impopularité le rebond j'ai
envie de dire pour l'instant à court
terme je ne le vois aucunement parce que
pour les Français la page des retraites
n'est pas soldée